a moment of history for the european and
ukrainian parliaments as they vote
simultaneously on the delayed
association agreement between the eu and
ukraine the event was relayed live
between kiev and strasbourg a bright
spot after months of war stoked many
argue by a kremlin leader obsessed with
ukraine's deepening euro-atlantic ties
upon
there were solid majorities in both
parliaments but it wasn't without
detractors more sympathetic to moscow
who argue no good will come of a rushed
procedure despite many breaches and
deaths ukraine's 11-day cease-fire is
deemed still alive
more than 2 500 people have been killed
as pro-russian rebels and russian forces
battle ukraine's army in self-declared
people's republics industry
where next russia's response is anyone's
guess though few of europe's farmers
forget the impact its tit-for-tat
produce embargo is having the agreement
provides for political association and
free trade ukraine must advance
political minority and judicial reforms
and fight corruption trade rules which
would have clashed with existing trade
arrangements with russia have been
deferred until 2016 at the request of
president poroshenko the russian
intention was
to change the agreement so that the vote
that they would not have been possible
and they did not achieve that after meps
voted on the agreement president
poroshenko presented draft legislation
to his parliament potentially giving
eastern ukrainians far more autonomy a
measure which could significantly reduce
tensions